Brian Philippi opens up about navigating
the holidays with ex-wife reese
witherspoon and their two kids yeah I'm
pretty excited about that
the circle star revealed he will not be
spending this Thanksgiving with his 13
year old son deacon and 17 year old
daughter Ava et spoke with the 42 year
old actor at the Innocence Project
benefit in New York City on Tuesday
where he talked about his family's plans
for the holidays explaining he and Reece
quote trade off years celebrating with
their children instead of having two big
family feasts Ryan said quote it is a
weird thing to do you want the kids
experience to be its own we have been
very good about that
very good very healthy about how we do
things it gets better and better
Philippi also talked movies and revealed
he's down for a Cruel Intentions sequel
quote I would be way into it I would
love to find another piece where I could
be that light comedic flippant master of
the character again I enjoyed shooting
that every day ciao